- Speaking of birthdays, is it true
that you performed at
birthday parties as a clown
when you were a kid?
- Oh yes.
- I love this.
And actually, I can see that happening.
- Yeah.
- [Eric] I mean, I have
been a clown, I think
oh there I am.
- [Kelly] This is awesome.
- So once, I mean, it's a
line in one of the episodes
of Modern Family.
Once I found out that clowns
were just regular people with makeup,
I was like, well, that's
what I wanna do with my life.
And so my grandma started
making me clown costumes
and I started putting on my mom's makeup.
- She loved that.
- This is where I always say
I'm so thankful for the
great parents that I had,
that my dad, being a Kansas
man and me a Kansas boy,
here I am, playing football, raising pigs,
taking karate, playing the drums,
and putting on my mom's makeup
and wanting to put on a wig
and he was just like, "Go for it!"
You know?
- Love it.
That's a real dad.
- 100% led me to right here.
- Yeah.
I love that though.
I think clowns is something
you love to make people laugh,
you love to make people feel good.
- Just wanna bring joy to people's lives.
- Exactly.
You're making a joke
but you truly love that.
- 100%.
That's what I tell Lindsey all the time.
- When she yells at me.
- I'm just bringing joy.
- You're 50!
Take the corn nuts somewhere else.